.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
"AC 360" STARTS NOW.
>>> THE EVENING RANG ESPECIALLY
HOLLOW TONIGHT.
A LITTLE BOY WHO JUST TURNED
THREE THIS WEEKEND IS NOW TWO
DAYS INTO A LIFETIME WITHOUT HIS
DAD.
HIS FATHER, ANDRE MACKNEIL, WAS
SHOT AND KILLED IN A SUPERMARKET
SATURDAY PICKING UP A SURPRISE
BIRTHDAY CAKE FOR HIS SON.
HE WAS MURDERED FOR THE COLOR OF
HIS SKIN.
ON HIS SON'S 3rd BIRTHDAY.
TEN PEOPLE WERE KILLED SATURDAY
AT TOPS FRIENDLY MARKET IN A
RACIALLY MOTIVATED ATTACK
ALLEGEDLY BY AN 18-YEAR-OLD
WHITE MAN WHO IS NOW IN CUSTODY.
WASN'T EVEN THE ONLY MASS
SHOOTING THIS WEEKEND.
WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THE
ALLEGED KILLER ALREADY.
HIS BACKGROUND, PRIOR RED FLAGS,
THE RACIST POISON HE APPARENTLY
DREW ON AND HOW WIDESPREAD IT
SADLY IS, AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT
ALL OF IT TONIGHT, BUT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO USE HIS NAME OR SHOW
HIS PHOTO.
HE LIVESTREAMED THE KILLINGS.
HE WANTS FAME.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE PART OF
GIVING HIM THAT.
INSTEAD, WE BEGIN TONIGHT BY
TELLING YOU WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THOSE WHOSE LIVES WERE STOLEN ON
SATURDAY, LIKE ANDRE MACKNEIL.
BY THE WAY, HE WENT EVERYWHERE,
WE'RE TOLD, WITH HIS SON.
HIS FIANCEE SAID HIS LITTLE BOY
WOULD FOLLOW HIS DAD LIKE A
SHADOW.
SATURDAY SHE SAID TODAY MY BABY
WAS BORN, BUT TODAY MY SOUL MATE
WAS TAKEN.
HOW DO I TELL MY SON HIS DADDY'S
NOT COMING HOME?
HOW DO I AS A MOTHER MAKE IT
OKAY?
SOMEONE PLEASE TELL ME BECAUSE I
REALLY DON'T KNOW.
ANDRE MACKNEIL WAS 53.
KATHERINE MASSEY WAS 72.
SHE WAS KNOWN AS KAT.
SHE WAS A COMMUNITY ACTIVIST, A
LETTER WRITER WHO CARED A LOT
ABOUT HER COMMUNITY AND
ADVOCATED FOR THEM AND HER CITY.
A YEAR AGO, SHE WROTE A LETTER
TO THE EDITOR OF THE BUFFALO
NEWS URGING FEDERAL ACTION TO
PREVENT SHOOTING DEATHS.
MARGUS MORRISON WAS A SCHOOL BUS
AIDE.
HE LOVED KIDS AND THEY LOVED HIM
BACK.
HE WAS A HERO TO HIS FAMILY AND
WENT OUT OF HIS WAY TO PROVIDE
FOR HIS DISABLED MOTHER.
MARGUS MORRISON DIED BUYING
SNACKS FOR MOVIE NIGHT WITH
THEM.
AARON SALTER JR., 55 YEARS OLD,
WAS A RETIRED BUFFALO POLICE
LIEUTENANT WORKING AS A STORE
SECURITY GUARD.
HE DIED PROTECTING SHOPPERS,
EXCHANGING GUNFIRE WITH THE
KILLER WEARING BODY ARMOR.
GERALDINE TALLEY'S NIECE
DESCRIBES HER AUNT AS THE LIFE
OF THE PARTY.
AN AVID BAKER AND THE ONE WHO
WOULD ALWAYS PUT FAMILY REUNIONS
TOGETHER.
SHE WAS 62.
RUTH WHITFIELD WAS 86 AND THE
MOTHER OF A FORMER BUFFALO FIRE
COMMISSIONER.
LOVED DEEPLY BY HER FAMILY.
PEARL YOUNG WAS 77 AND STILL
SERVING AS A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER
IN THE BUFFALO PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
SHE CARED ABOUT KIDS THAT MUCH.
HER FAMILY DESCRIBES HER AS A
DREW PILLAR OF THE COMMUNITY.
SELL ASTEEN CHENEY WAS A
GRANDMOTHER OF SIX.
SHE SURVIVED BREAST CANCER AND
BRAIN ANEURYSMS BEFORE THAT.
A FIGHTER, SAYS HER GRANDSON WHO
TELLS US THERE WAS NEVER A DULL
MOMENT WITH HER.
SHE WAS ALWAYS LAUGHING, HE
SAID.
SPREADING JOY AND LOVE.
ROBERTA DRURY WAS ONLY 32.
HER BROTHER SAYS SHE DEDICATED
MUCH OF HER TIME TO HELPING HIM
WITH HIS LEUKEMIA TREATMENT AND
HELPING HER FAMILY AT THE LOCAL
RESTAURANT THEY OWNED.
SHE SAID SHE WAS A HAPPY PERSON
WHO ALWAYS TRIED TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
AND 67-YEAR-OLD HEYWARD
PATTERSON WAS A TAXI DRIVER, A
DEACON AT HIS CHURCH, HIS NEPHEW
SAYS HE TOOK PRIDE IN HELPING
PEOPLE.
SOMEONE WHO WOULD GIVE SOMEONE A
FREE RID